ففعلا بدا العشرات وصل العدد ربما الى
المئات وسيزداد بحسب المتظاهرين تحديدا في
ساحه الرصافي التي هي من خلفي طبعا لا
تبعد سواء بعض الامتار همم نايف هذه
التجمعات كان قد دعى اليها ناشطون في حركه
تشرين وبعض الفعاليات المدنيه تحديدا في
محافظه النجف ومحافظه بابل اضافه الى يعني
بعض النشطين في محافظات الجنوب وما موجود
هنا طبعا في العاصمه بغداد هذه التظاهرات
تاتي بسبب ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار امام
الدينار من المقرر بعد نصف ساعه او ساعه
من الان تاتي هذه التظاهره نايف الى هذا
المكان من خلفي تحديدا بنايه البنك
المركزي وهي همم مكان همم الذي طبعا يحاول
المتظاهرون الوصول اليه بعد اكتمال
الاعداد هناك اعداد من المحافظات الجنوبيه
حتى الساعه الى مكان همم التظاهره الان هو
مجرد تجمع على ما يبدو ان الساعه القادمه
ستشهد هذه التظاهره همم سالتني عن ما هي
المطالبات التي يرفعها والشعارات التي
يرفعها المتظاهرون الجميع هنا يطالب بخفض
سعر صرف الدولار الى ما كان عليه سابقا اي
بمعنى ليس السعر الحالي وهو
147 همم
مقابل الدولار مقابل ال 100$ البعض يطالب
بالعوده الى 120 دولار وهو السعر السابق
لسعر الصرف همم الدولار مقابل الدينار طيب
ممتاز يعني نحن نريد فقط خلفيه سريعه سامر
عن ما حدث لنا
العراقي خلال الاشهر ال- ال- الماضيه يعني
باختصار اذا سمحت حتى يكون المشاهد على
علم بسبب هذه
الاحتجاجات المطالبات كذلك ايضا من الشارع
العراقي
سامر طيب يبدو ان فقدنا صوت الزميل سامر
الكبيسي سنه
نعود اليه سامر هل تسمعني
طيب ابدو فعلا انا فقدنا الاتصال لكن لا
نفقد الصوره طبعا التي ينقلها
لنا سمير الكبيسي والمصور ايضا من العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد والتي تشهد الان تظاهرات
بالقرب من البنك المركزي في العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد
احتجاجا على ارتفاع سعر صرف همم الدولار
مقابل الدينار همم العراقي طبعا يعني كانت
هناك همم انباء عن زياره محتمله لرئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد السوداني الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لمحاوله بحث
همم
العمله العراقيه وارتفاع السعر الصرف امام
الدولار الامريكي همم الاحتجاجات كما
ذكرنا هذا اليوم ابرز الشعارات تطالب همم
سعر العمله المحليه الدينار العراقي همم
مقابل الدولار والتي ارتفعت خلال الايام
والاشهر القليله الماضيه